don à dijon le verdict dans la sphère
villemin la rose devrait être en
principe connu en milieu de semaine
prochaine
les débats sont clos depuis ce soir mais
il ne semble guère avoir apporté la
lumière commentaires de notre envoyée
spéciale dominique verdeilhan claude
collin aurait voulu rester au second
plan j'ai tiré un trait sur cette
affaire dit il
à tel point que je ne voulais plus lire
les journaux être le 123e et dernier
témoin leur ai joué à moitié certes
dit-il je libère ma conscience mais je
devinais aussi tout ce qui allait me
tomber sur le dos si claude collin est
entendu au dernier jour des débats c'est
aussi parce que son témoignage a été
tardif
six ans après les faits claude collin
est précédée par la rumeur depuis trois
jours des témoins sont venus dire ce que
l'homme avait vu les détails ne
manquaient pas
claude collin devait être le témoin de
la dernière chance déterminant accablant
capitale la cour d'assises doit
déchanter
certes il déclare avoir croisé vers 17
heures en compagnie de madame claude ont
une voiture le conducteur était un homme
corpulent en une fraction de seconde il
a distingué une chevelure rousse mais
claude collin dit n'avoir noté aucun
autre détail ni couleur ni type de
véhicule aucun enfant à bord et devant
l'aso de questions le témoin agacé
irrité prévient je dis ce que j'ai vu
pas ce que les gens disent depuis dix
ans
mais marcel claudon sa passagère nous
donne pas la même version
elle n'a vu aucune voiture ainsi donc
cette ultime déposition n'a aucune
valeur de preuve on peut tout juste
parler de coïncidence troublante
deuxième déception pour ceux qui
espéraient aussi que l'interrogatoire de
muriel bolle la semaine dernière lève le
voile définitivement envolés les espoirs
de voir élucider le mystère de la
vologne
le président ruyssen lui même n'avait
pas caché son souhait de réussir là où
la justice a pataugé durant neuf ans
seule la vérité apportera la paix
avait-il dit hélas la cour d'assises ne
s'est pas transformé en confessionnal